un cinquième budget monsieur Gérard
bonsoir bonsoir par rapport aux autres
est-ce que celui-là était difficile plus
facile à écrire je vous dirais que
celui-ci est plus important parce que il
va donner le ton au deuxième mandat et
nous sommes une équipe plus expérimentée
c'est notre deuxième mandat il faut
faire une différence pour les Québécois
il faut que les services s'améliorent en
éducation il faut que le plan santé
fonctionne et il faut que l'économie
monte à un autre niveau bref
le premier budget d'un deuxième mandat
c'est extrêmement important et là bon
alors il y a les baisses d'impôts c'est
le gros morceau de votre budget on va
voir un tableau on va répéter au Japon
les c'est les deux premiers paliers
d'imposition que vous faites baisser
d'un point pourcentage ce qui veut dire
très concrètement pour quelqu'un qui
gagne 20 000 c'est 8 dollars quelqu'un
qui gagne 60428 et le maximum la
réduction d'impôts parce qu'au-delà du
100 000 il y en a plus de réduction
c'est 814 dollars alors il y a des gens
qui ont d'abord il y a des gens qui vous
posent la question est-ce qu'on avait
les moyens de baisser les impôts après
ça je vous demanderai la manière de le
faire mais a-t-on les moyens de baisser
les impôts alors que les besoins
explosent oui le choix que nous avons
fait parce que nous devions donner des
nouveaux objectifs de réduction dette à
long terme alors parce que on avait
atteint la cible de d'être brute qu'on
s'était donné en 2006 et là on va
continuer de réduire notre dette
présentement je vais je vais simplifier
le tout on est à 37,5% de dette net par
rapport au PIB on va rejoindre la cible
de 30% en 15 si il n'y avait pas eu de
baisse d'impôts on aurait pu le faire en
10 ans alors le choix qu'on a décidé
c'est le choix que nous avons fait c'est
de réduire la dette de façon plus
progress pour permettre un allègement
fiscal qui va stimuler l'économie à
croître l'offre de travail d'ailleurs on
a le tableau là on avait bien fait le
tableau d'être 207 milliards et 2032 le
vote cible c'est 33% du PIB j'entends ce
que vous dites mais si il y a des
besoins non prévus c'est-à-dire des
besoins parce qu'il y a une récession
parce que le pont Louis est poli de la
Fontaine coûte un milliard de plus parce
qu'en santé il y a des feux à éteindre
parce qu'un éducation il faut bâtir ça
coûte plus cher bâtir l'argent que vous
prenez que vous alliez mettre sur la
dette plus vite vous pourrez vous auriez
pu le prendre pour plus de services
publics aussi mais les services publics
sont bien financiers monsieur Roy depuis
que nous sommes au pouvoir on a financé
la santé l'éducation l'enseignement
supérieur de façon adéquate on aurait
répondu présent dans ce budget là encore
une fois il y a des taux de croissance
important
des dépenses en santé croissent de façon
importante alors on s'occupe des
missions de l'État mais on a voulu
donner de l'oxygène à l'économie
québécoise stimuler l'offre de travail
les Québécois ont un fardeau fiscal
extrêmement élevé et c'est tellement le
moment de les aider c'était notre
engagement nous avions pris en campagne
électorale donc on peut faire ça ce que
vous dites votre plaidoyer c'est qu'on
peut faire ça en restant prudent en se
gardant des marges de manœuvre si
l'hiver s'en vient aussi le les gros
ventes
de provisions dans le cadre financier
pour les incertitudes on a un scénario
alternatif où il y a une récession qui
montre que ça nous coûterait
approximativement 5 milliards de dollars
alors on a des provisions on a le retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire en 27 28 après
contribution font les générations parce
qu'au sens des comptes publics le revenu
dépenses lorsqu'on utilise la même
définition que le Canada ou l'Ontario on
va être à l'équilibre en 25 26 et si on
utilise pas l'approvision en 23 24 on
serait à l'équilibre alors les finances
publiques sont solides retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire en 27 28
réduction de la dette sur un horizon 15
ans réduction du fardeau fiscal mission
de l'État bien financier deux petites
questions est-ce que
est-ce que l'objectif c'est dans mener
d'eau d'en faire d'autres et baisse
d'impôts pour se rapprocher encore plus
de l'Ontario par exemple parce que vous
avez dit aujourd'hui apparemment on
reste au Québec les plus taxés les plus
imposés oui après c'est à dire que là on
a une prévision d'équilibre budgétaire
après contribution au fond de
générations en 2027-2028 pour considérer
de nouvelles bases d'impôts il faudra
d'abord atteindre cette équilibre
végétal après contributions
en surplus
dans trois ans mais pour l'instant le
plan le déficit cette année c'est 4
milliards trois l'an prochain 2 1 0 donc
chaque chose en son temps c'est ça donc
c'est si vos baisses d'impôts du mandat
c'est ce qui est prévu très bien c'est
ce que c'est ce que c'était notre
engagement aussi sur la manière je vous
remontre le tableau donc 8 dollars pour
20.000 814 100 000 est-ce que ça bon là
vous y allez général tout le monde qui
pète l’impôt Québec va voir des
réductions d'impôts là vous touchez
parce que le premier taux d'imposition
parce qu'on a un impôt progressif moins
de gens payent le deuxième palier parce
qu'il faut gagner plus de 40.000 c'est
ça donc vous touchez tout le monde
est-ce que vous auriez pas pu est-ce que
vous avez été tenté de toucher moins de
monde mais plus de baisse pour ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin
mais en fait tout ce il y a quatre
points 6 millions de Québécois qui fait
de l'impôt tout le monde paie le premier
palier et le de 0 à 49000 alors c'est
l'impôt est progressif donc à partir du
moment où on veut réduire l'impôt sur le
revenu de ceux qui gagnent le moins ce
que vous suggérez ben nécessairement
tout le monde a en bénéficie parce que
tout le monde paie le premier palier
d'imposition entre 17000 et 40000 c'est
la première marche que tout le monde
voilà il y en a qui sont plus haut dans
l'escalier mais c'est la première marche
il y en a eu d'autres façons d'aider les
plus bas revenus par exemple mais on
fait plusieurs choses pour les plus
beaux revenus parce que j'entends la
critique on me dit mais pourquoi vous
avez des pas les gens qui gagnent moins
de 20 000 pourquoi vous avez des pas les
gens qui gagnent moins de 30000 mais
d'abord faut bien se dire que à
l'automne j'ai introduit un crédit
d'impôt pour les années plus de 70 ans
qui affaiblir 2000 dollars ça ça touche
un million de personnes
ensuite le régime fiscal tous les
crédits d'impôts les allocations
familles le crédit d'impôt solidarité
ont été indexés à
6.4%. et on fait plusieurs gestes au
Québec 2023 c'est l'année du programme
de revenus de base pour les gens qui
sont sur la solidarité sociale avec des
contraintes sévères à l'emploi on a le
régime le plus généreux il rentre en
fonction en 2023 très bien on en fait
des choses mais aujourd'hui c'était pour
les 4.6 millions de Québécois qui
travaillent qui pètent l'impôt et qui
ont des besoins et c'est important de le
faire monsieur Gérard merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous expliquer tout ça
aujourd'hui merci bonne suite merci
beaucoup au revoir